[Music]
for airbus and the aeronautics industry
in general artificial intelligence
is much more than a field of research
it is an essential technology of the future
which invests in
all areas of our society
the potential for
using  artificial intelligence
in aeronautics is very vast
it can help us to develop
lighter aircraft with a longer lifespan that
consume less fuel
and therefore reduce their environmental impact
it can optimize the detection of
material defects in production but
also make
in-service preventive maintenance can improve
the flight experience just as it can
increase the fluidity and safety of
our airspaces by supporting the
work of controllers and at airbus
we believe that
artificial intelligence is a key technology that
will allow us to  make the most of the
billions of data generated every
day by our aircraft that's why  we have been
studying it and putting it into practice
for a long time
for example we have been using an
artificial neural network to adjust the
rotor blades of our helicopters
since 2005
more recently in 2020 we have
flight tested software to take
off and land an a350
thanks to an
image recognition system coupled with
automatic learning algorithms called
machine learning in English, such a
demonstrator is intended to
mature its advanced technologies
before deploying them in our products in
a safe way but moving on to the phase
of  industrialization involves guaranteeing
the highest level of safety to which
our industry is committed for this
we rely on a
well-controlled certification process it defines
the rules and practices guaranteeing
the quality of our design work
through its novelty and complexity
artificial intelligence forces us
to review and adapt our development
cycle  development
we must review with the
certification authorities some of the standards that
apply to us and adapt our
means of validation and verification
it will not be necessary to change the requirements
and standards applicable in our
index
yes accordingly this is why we are
placing large  hopes in the
consortium confidence of interest we
strongly believe in this model
encouraging cooperation and
exchanges between industrial researchers and
academics through the diversity and
complementarity of our skills we
can go faster further
together in the application
of artificial intelligence  in a
safe way in our products on an industrial scale
for this we expect from trust
dated haye that he proposes a
development framework mature enough to
allow us rapid industrialization
of the solutions proposed and
consistent with the framework of a generous
system that supports  today our
process of c  ertification
with this we will be able to
tap the full potential
of artificial intelligence for
our planes and helicopters in the short term this
is a major challenge for our
industry we are counting on you
[Music]